jessica is with us in Indianapolis hi
Jessica how are you better than I
deserve
how are you better than I deserve what's
up all right so I am currently a college
student in my second year second
semester and I have managed to pay for
school with my parents help cash good
right hard yeah I was really hard but
now my cash flow is coming to a really
low level and I can actually pay for
this year but next year I'm going to
have a really big struggle so how do I
convince my parents that I don't want to
take out loans and I would rather
transfer schools how do I convince them
that that's the right choice for me okay
how much is the school right now for
tuition I pay about five thousand
dollars a semester out of pocket right
here what year are you I am a sophomore
right now okay and so you've got this
year taken care of but your junior and
senior year you're going to be
struggling to do that yes miss ten
thousand dollars a year right yes okay
our pocket and how much of that are you
paying um well this year I am paying for
um well okay out of my pocket I
currently have about three and a half
thousand dollars in savings no how much
how much how much would you have to pay
in your junior and senior year that your
parents could not cover Oh how much is
that I'm probably about twelve and a
half
thirteen so they're not going to cover
anything there's no not not mad women
it's ten thousand dollars a year
yeah okay so how would we talk about
nine thousand dollars a year kind let me
stop that stop stop I'm confused with
the numbers you talking about twelve and
a half to finish both years yes oh okay
so like sixty so like six thousand
dollars a year you need yes and you make
nine thousand yeah but I also have a car
payment and I'm buying off of my parents
and
how much as rain I pay about 150 a month
okay probably rather you sell the car
that I wouldn't get you a beater of some
kind and I would change schools because
your schools not that outrageous $10,000
a year tuition is not outrageous what
school are you going to I actually um
have a really good scholarship through
the University of Indianapolis okay and
that's helping okay
the scholarship cutting down your cost I
see yeah and how many hours a week how
many hours are you working I need my car
to go to my job which is the problem but
I work at you need a car to go to your
job you don't need your car
correct I work about 20 hours a week and
through UPS I actually get another
scholarship oh you're working for UPS
yes good paying for the whole thing what
do you mean UPS in some cities pays for
the whole thing I guess not this
particular university though okay yeah
some cities if you work part-time for
UPS they'll just pick up your tuition
mm-hmm notice where I'm working at they
have a tuition reimbursement program
yeah so I'll get reimbursed at the end
of the semester but can you get more oh
[ __ ] not without losing some my grades
well they're really important how do you
know um last year I worked about 30 to
35 hours a week which is why I was able
to go debt-free all of last year without
even having to think oh my gosh I need
to work money and my GPA was not at the
level that I would like yeah what was
your GPA what was the level my GPA level
was about a two point eight oh two point
nine but on three I am not working as
many hours I'm able to get it up to a
three point oh so you pick up a tenth of
a point a 2.8 a two point nine versus a
three point oh yeah okay and what are
you studying right now it's chemistry
and medical laboratory sciences what are
you going to do hopefully one day work
in a medical lab in a hospice
I'm doing lab write-ups and blood typing
mm-hmm
and um okay cool cool well you're
obviously bright and you're obviously a
hard worker I actually think I would
pick up more hours and try and fight my
way through the GPA issue if you were
telling me you're dropping a full grade
point or something we talked about it
but you're dropping a tenth of a point
when you went from a 302 nine or to
eight you're dropping 1010 third or
fifth of a point you know it's not it's
not that much and usually that's not
going to be a job disqualifier a two
point eight versus a 3.0 in very rare
circumstances would that be would that
come up now if you're trying to qualify
for medical school or something like
that it might be a different equation
but I'm going to fight my way through
this and the other thing I'd do is ask
my parents is there anything that we can
do at home to help me do this because if
I can't get this figured out mom and dad
I'm not willing to go into that and I
wouldn't have to transfer to a different
school now the transfer to a different
school would be how much what would be
the savings well it would probably be
about five thousand dollars in savings
because I would move back home and then
I would just be able to pay tuition
through a local university okay all
right well I mean that's an option and
it's not a bad option if you can finish
still finish out if everything transfers
and you can finish out in the same
period of time the school you're at
you've almost got it though I mean
you're right on the cusp you know right
on the edge of being able to do it so I
you know and count you know also count
the summers where you can work 80 hours
a week you know and just go crazy in the
summer and just pile up big big piles of
cash so I don't I talked it through with
them some more but I think it's okay for
you to throw down the gauntlet and go
I'm just not willing to go into debt I'm
not going into debt so let's figure help
me figure this out where I don't go into
that cuz I either got to move back home
and go to this school or I got to pick
up more hours or something but would you
all look at it mom and dad with me and
help me figure out how I can do it
without that hey guys Rachael Cruz here
hope you enjoyed that video from the
Dave
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below